[Music]
President Trump is expected to sign an
online sex trafficking bill in the
coming days we reported last week the
Senate passed the bill it would penalize
websites that facilitate sex trafficking
Craigslist already responded by pulling
its personal section Michelle Miller has
been following the story of one young
woman caught up in the sex trafficking
of children actor and activist Ashton
Kutcher has taken on this cause to save
other young victims it's the focus of
tomorrow night's 48 hours Michelle good
morning good morning
Alyssa Beck was just a naive 15 year old
living in Jacksonville Florida when she
found herself trapped in a sex
traffickers web according to the FBI sex
trafficking of children in this country
has become a nationwide problem and
traffickers target troubled girls with
low self-esteem girls just like Alyssa I
was searching for something but I didn't
know what I was searching for Alyssa
Beck grew up a good student in a
middle-class neighborhood but in her
early teens she started breaking her
parents rules by staying out late and
hanging out with boys part of it was me
being a rebellious teenager and honestly
really just being a child but also
because my father and mother they you
know they had problems of their own
after running away from home for almost
a year
Alyssa ended up in the juvenile justice
system if you have a child who needs
counseling and who needs help because
they've been through some serious trauma
they're going to probably find worse
friends
sure enough Alyssa met a 17 year old who
encouraged her to flee the facility she
ended up in Jacksonville Sin City a
dangerous crime ridden area with a lot
of motels and a lot of men men who
pretended to care about her I thought
these guys were my boyfriends they gave
me food they gave me the clothes that I
needed but things quickly change when
Alyssa was introduced to Ian Shaun
Gordon I remember him just really
brutally beating me and raping me
and then he started taking pictures of
me and I heard him starting to call
people and telling them hey I have this
girl here you can come do whatever you
wanted to her just for $20
how many men 50 over the course of two
weeks Alyssa would be in and out of the
trap of traffickers for almost five
years Alyssa had such a vivid
recollection and such a detailed memory
of what had happened she gave us the the
map so to speak to go create cases
against these people Alyssa's work with
the Jacksonville human trafficking task
force led to the arrest of seven people
who were involved in buying or
trafficking her Ian Shaun Gordon
received one of the first life sentences
ever given to a sex trafficker these
victims find safety in someone anyone
anywhere that will show what they think
is love actor and activist Ashton
Kutcher has taken on this issue where
it's happening online are you a slave in
2009 he and Demi Moore created the
nonprofit company thorn we build
technology to help fight the sexual
exploitation of children we basically
take a victim and connect connect them
with someone that can help
now one of thorns tech tools spotlight
did not exist in time to help ELISA
it is now being used by some 6,000 law
enforcement agencies across the country
in Norah this software is so successful
it's identifying five victims every
single day that is some good news there
Michelle thank you so much and you can
see live to tell traffic that's tomorrow
night on 48 hours it airs at 10:00 9:00
central right here on CBS